on est 12 millions de citoyens et demi
au ban de la société à ne pas nous ne
nous écoute pas on nous entend pas
c'était en 2015
les handicapés pousse un coup de gueule
de nombreux lieux publics ne sont
toujours pas accessibles pour eux alors
qu'une loi la loi handicap devait tout
changer
l'adoption de la loi sur le handicap
s'est éteint hier à l'assemblée un pas
en avant important pour assurer
l'égalité des droits et des chances
cette loi votée en 2005 est un
soulagement
elle prévoit de rendre accessibles les
lieux publics et les transports aux
handicapés d'ici 2015 un texte
prometteur pourtant quelques mois après
l'adoption de la loi
son financement est déjà remis en
question la loi prévoit y ait dans un
délai de dix ans or au maxi 6 mai
transports en commun les bâtiments etc
et semblerait maintenant que le projet
de décret se retranche derrière des
dérogations économique en 2010 cinq ans
après l'adoption de la loi
le chemin est encore très long de
nombreux efforts restent à faire exemple
avec la ville d'evreux tant que les
trottoirs ne seront pas refait mais
quand je lis seront pas repris c'est à
dire seront pas surélevé pour revenir au
niveau
la plupart des commerçants ils seront
pas accessibles en 2014
un an avant l'échéance coup dur pour les
handicapés le gouvernement décide de
rallonger les délais de mises aux normes
trois ans pour les commerces de
proximité où les bus de ville
le calvaire continue
on est fatigués de tout ça dans dix ans
dans dix ans d'ailleurs il y en a
beaucoup qui n'existeront plus parmi
nous donc c'est maintenant que l'on de
vivre les délais vont même jusqu'à 9 ans
soit 2024 pour les monuments historiques
et les gares ferroviaires une situation
dénoncée par l'association des paralysés
de france
ça fait quand même des années qu'on se
bat pour l'accessibilité jeudi tout en
symbole un handicap parce qu'on a notre
handicap physique est aussi un handicap
d'accessibilité est-ce qu'on peut pas
aller partout il faut choisir ces
endroits se renseigner et ça devient un
combat c'est très compliqué en 2015
alors que tous les lieux publics
devaient être accessible c'est un
constat d'échec pour la loi handicap
malheureusement l'objectif est pas
remplie faute de politiques publiques
faute de visibilité effectivement de la
loi par les acteurs de terrain faute de
mesures budgétaires ou d'incitation
fiscale aurait permis aux acteurs de
terrain d'appliquer la loi aujourd'hui
sur plus d'un million de lieux publics
seuls 350 milles sont accessibles aux
handicapés
[Musique]